I blame the self-checkout things at
Walmart they make it so easy to Jack I
was like if I was I think that's one of
the argument points yeah it is yeah I
would have been like Pete okay I'm done
and I just
cracked
[Music]
apparently Canadians are now stealing
overpriced food from grocery stores with
zero remorse good that is not my Canada
what's your Canada
sorry sorry sorry sorry what are you
talking about wait you're talking about
just across Canada everyone's just
jacking [__] that sounds like some
Montreal Behavior to me Montreal
so apparently grocery store in like uh
grocery inflation has gone to such a
like a ridiculous amount that people are
just revolting and just like [__] this
so they're just starting to steal at
like these high-end grocery stores like
Whole Foods both in one way I think to
kind of like prove a point and also
because it's like yo we don't have
enough money and they're just starting
to Resort towards being like [__] it
what kind of items Anthony oh you know
Trader Mings and uh you know is that
like a startup a revolution because
that's what happens right like they
start stealing bread or whatever they
feel like their money doesn't go far
enough are eggs pretty expensive right
now that's what everyone's saying that's
the meme what's the price on eggs right
now for a carton I saw like 6.99 for a
second
yeah so people have been shoplifting
from major Canadian Grocery Stores
um or supporting those who do so in
retaliation against rampant green
inflation
um basically they're also talking about
it's not the store's fault what the [__]
no yeah it's not the last retail or the
chain markets margins are so small the
hard part is like you know like the
grocery store is kind of like just the
middle men exactly right yeah but that
is that is kind of the platform of
delivery to the end user right I mean
it's America's fault for printing out so
much money it's a low IQ response yeah
it's like the hell are you blaming the
[__] you gotta steal from the farmers
dude
uh you know in terms of one pool in
terms of where they're at rate of
inflation is rising like astronomically
um but so for them things are harder
whereas for corporate Giants they're
pulling in record profits so go rob the
corporate Giants how do you do that yeah
dude like how do you stick it to the man
when you're at the lowest level right
you wait outside
invest in Kroger during coven he
probably knew
who did Warren Buffett he invested mad
heavy in Kroger during covid
um and so it just seemed like oh well
he's probably onto something about the
grocery stores things are way more
expensive though like like chicken
breasts used to be what like five six
bucks for a pound now they're like like
damn near 10 bucks which is pretty
expensive even at the Asian ones because
they're usually cheaper yeah but I think
for most people when they shop in
America that's like I mean they're more
expensive don't go there
99 it's terrible so you go to the place
where it's cheaper and they drive up the
sale price because everybody's going
yeah yeah no that's really expensive
two waste of time don't even check don't
even check it it costs unless you to go
to Ono Hawaiian Barbecue and get the
chicken there already cooked yeah for
real but the five dollar chickens at
like Ralph's or Costco is still five
dollars right yep like 5.99 depends on
where you're at that's because the
savings are being passed down to US
savings are being passed out get passed
down how does Costco do at [__] 199
hot dog and a drink they take the hit
oh because they're real business model
is the subscription my buddy says uh
eggs at Costco's are like normal price
it's normal price but also they're uh
they just locked into deals too like the
the well as a Costco sell yeah remember
though like Costco is already getting
their discount from the from the Creator
or for the from The Producers or
whatever the [__] right the wholesalers
yeah the way that like you know if you
create a product that wants to go into
Costco you're doing high high crazy
numbers high volume and then yeah high
volume and you're doing it at like
really like really low pricing I'm
talking like over 30 percent cheaper
than like the next cheapest thing that
you sell your wholesale price so when
you sell your Kindred Banks to Costco
did you just sell them at wholesale
price
cheaper than regular so you were saying
I remember you were saying before that
you guys put in kenja Bank in Costco is
more of a strategic move than it is a
profit move on for the sake of any other
further conversations regarding this I'm
going to redact both the word Costco and
consider bang and just like speak
hypothetically and allegedly okay long
shame we're talking about as a Kirkland
supporter right so you see this
we all like to get Kirkland products
water bottles all that stuff right so
like they are in they have they're like
they have the whole chain you know what
I mean like they they don't buy it like
from Kirkland water they own the
manufacture part of it or they do all
these different parts they got the
glacier so they could just cut the chips
they got to cut the glue like seeing
sugar like they oh they they subsidize
CNA sugar they have they're invested
into it so they're just double dipping
that's all I'm saying man and then on
top of that too it's like let's say this
guy makes like jumbi matcha right and
then we're like okay cool like we want
to put your jumbee Mantra in our stores
but you got to give us like 30 discount
off your wholesale and then on top of
that if you start doing kind of well and
we're like this product does kind of
move then we're like hey Mr dreamy
monster you want to make Kirkland matcha
and we're gonna sell at this price and
we're gonna collaborate on it as a you
know and guess what oh you can't afford
it no more I guess I can buy a company
for you if you're if you're struggling
and that's all and then it's like hey
we'll put your dream watch on like 10
stores which is like [__] amazing but
we're like hey if we do crook the matcha
though you're only gonna get five
percent of it but we're gonna put in
like 3 000 stores yeah would you rather
have one percent of a billion dollars or
a hundred percent of a thousand dollars
and if you put it that way I'm like geez
a thousand dollars I'll take the second
one percent allegedly quick math
everything's Case by cases yeah I would
have taken a thousand because I'm like
big fish in a small pond [__] peace but
I mean like what what you know let's
let's talk kind of like Common Sense
basic stuff that maybe not everybody's
always thinking uh every day right like
even in America you're seeing what a
[__] ton of inflation things are just
getting more expensive but then
opportunities or like jobs gonna cut
whatever it might be like how does the
lower middle class or how does the lower
income class like what do you do how do
you not turn into a bunch of Aladdin's
yeah what position does it put you in
you know and at one point especially if
you have a family or you know like lives
on the line what what is the moral
obligation for you for your family still
if my kids were hungry all day I'm going
to Whole Foods I'm getting the really
nice [__] duck things that they got
the pate and then if my kids need
gluten-free [__] I'm getting all that
[__] yeah steal some kombucha hell yeah
dude and one of them's lactose so I'm
gonna get like soy milk you know you
said thoughtful baby yeah I appreciate
you you gotta get all that steal some
super green powders yup like even in
um what's called Walmart had to put out
a statement like a couple weeks ago
talking about how like theft and Walmart
has reached such an all-time high and
for them theft of them like they might
only like lose like one or two percent
of like Revenue to theft but one or two
percent to a conglomerate like them is
like three billion dollars annually or
some [__] like that I blame the [__]
self-checkout things at Walmart they
make it so easy to Jack dude I was like
if I was I think that's one of the
argument points yeah it is yeah I would
have been like beat
no they got hell
level doing that you
used to check out they got like two
items right and they'll be like beep
beep you know what I'm saying and it's
just like they're just moving and
placing it there and that's it sometimes
it's probably more convenient to just
steal because like I'll go to Home Depot
and I get like eight screws or whatever
and I'm like beep
you see the line you're like yeah I'm
like
but I keep going it's so easy to just go
you know just yeah you know what [__]
me up is the fruits dude you gotta put
the bananas on wait for it to weigh yeah
look for the right one and then you um
you scan the apple and then you gotta
look is it Fuji Gala is it green which
one is it in the uh okay so how many
times have you like deliberately picked
the the cheaper one but it's still in
the Apple category but you picked the
cheapest so it's not large Fuji or it's
it's like the small one oh I didn't even
know the prices were different
especially organic ones I always just
look for the closest picture I've never
even looked at the price dude the
organic thing is such a scam such a scam
there's a video of this guy who uh stole
the Walmart security camera he just took
it off the thing and then put a label on
it and then he went to the regular
checkout and Elijah went
and he bought it for like 10 bucks
that's so tight I mean it's Walmart dude
the actual security camera to answer
your question like if it was like um
like let's say I was like a regular dude
maybe I was a teacher or something and I
had a family and now I got hit with that
question like what do I do if like I
feel like I'm getting like choked from
all sides I would probably look for the
place where my dollar stretched the
furthest like [__] North Carolina or
some place where it's like 1.99 for a
tank of gas still and probably just move
and just like we just gotta start over
you know start fresh yeah but what if
the jobs aren't
there like the cost is low but so are
the jobs so I would have to do
calculations
you'd find the ratio what jobs could I
do here like could I be construction I
might have to like change Industries but
then look at like you know what the
general rule of thumb is like you want
your rent or your mortgage to be like a
third of what you make yeah so I'm like
in which one of these areas could I do
something and how much is the rent and
that fits in that ratio that puts me in
a safe space and then we'll just have to
go over there that's a lucky thing
though that like not because the cost of
living crisis is hidden everywhere but
most places are small so you can maybe
have like a slight difference between
going from City to suburb but in America
like you still have so many options it's
drastic in America drastic and so you
have the option of being like okay this
isn't working let's go here and you have
those that freedom of movement which you
just need gas money or a Greyhound
ticket at the same house in one state
could be a hundred grand in another
State's a million yeah and the same
exact house is [__] crazy most
drastic like even in the UK London is
the most expensive but like going
between City to town like there's
there's a slight change but it's not
going to be drastic enough to really
make a difference on your life whereas
like going from California to Vegas you
can be a different person and you have
that like freedom of movement that isn't
available to everybody so I think
there's like it's bad everywhere but
there is options here right there yeah
dude a lot of my clients it's it's
pretty frequent for them to have two
jobs yeah like I have a couple of
clients who like programmers and they're
they're working two different jobs at
the same time marketing guys working two
jobs at the same time constantly on top
of like the side projects they're doing
so it's like it does seem like there's a
lot more opportunity out here especially
in California right in La like there's
just so we got two jobs here you know we
got like three jobs we all got two or
three jobs yeah everyone moves to the
big city like because there's not enough
work in the small towns outside yes it's
more affordable but I think there's less
opportunities and jobs and well-paid
jobs because even in Hawaii that's the
issue is like everything's either
tourism and all the decent jobs they pay
less than they do on the mainland but
the cost of living is like more than La
yeah so you're paying like a million
dollars for a house that's breaking down
that was built in 1920 yeah you know and
then it's like got one Beth Bath one
shower and one big hole but it's still a
big hole but it's just got like this
like slice and a friendly Samoan in the
back there's also this like weird
dichotomy of like
um maybe the people are expecting the
government to do something they're the
ones that [__] it up and the
government's expecting the people to
figure it out they're not gonna do [__]
you know what I'm saying fend for
yourself yo that's all you got but I
feel like the policy makers and the
people that are up there they're so
shielded they don't see the everyday
[__] like most of those like people in
Washington that are at the highest level
they're not shopping at [__] Walmart
they're not they're with their security
like they're like living in gated
communities like they're not walking
around with us and they're probably so
rich they're like I can't tell the
difference between who my eggs were like
two dollars or what not six dollars yeah
they're not looking they're just looking
they just buy it like everyone
oh dude everyone's a [__] joke bro
and most of the times you as normal
people when you go grocery shopping you
have to go to multiple uh markets you're
not just going to One Market Day all
your [__] that's unheard of like you got
to go to the things I'm saying but even
then you're like uh should I buy this
here super targets are pretty gangster
Super Target we don't I don't got a
Super Target but they don't got the
Asian [__] yeah that's true
like that's the hard part and then you
go to the Asian market and a [__]
thing of Folgers awesome 15 bucks bro
all the American stuff is so all
American [__] at the Asian stores are
like super overpriced but then their
veggies are like really cheap sometimes
the Mexican restaurant uh Mexican
restaurants the Mexican uh supermarkets
they got some really good deals for
really good like certain things but you
have to keep scattering yourself like
socks that go up to your knees all right
[Laughter]
It's hard out here man you gotta keep
driving everywhere
[Music]
foreign